suppose someone is at that threshold
where they've risen to a certain level
and they think that things were so
supposed to be so much more glorious
than they are do they reinvent
themselves do they really why they did
this what are some of the tips they can
do to stay in the game and have meaning
well that's actually the two that you
brought are the smart things to do one
reevaluate because I think understanding
yourself is really important I will use
the example of psychologists one of the
requirements if you want to be a shrink
is you have to actually go get therapy
and what they found is that there's a
lot of people who go into the profession
because of the fact that they themselves
are trying to work through their own
issues sometimes we're not always aware
of our motives are I can speak very
candidly about the motive to be heard I
go a minor and what my I don't want to
pull them demons because they're not
necessarily a bad thing it could be a
great thing that motivates you to be
whatever it is you want to be but there
are things inside of you that motivates
you to make certain career choices so I
think when you get to a place you might
just find that you've accomplished that
goal it's kind of like the guy who's you
know he spends his entire life like in
the princess bride movie I saw growing
up and he's chasing the guy with I think
he had six fingers as opposed to find
he's chasing six finger banger oddity
because he killed his father and he had
the speech all worked out and he says my
name is so it's all and you killed my
father prepare to die and then in the
end he gets his revenge he kills the guy
they just want to do with himself
because his whole life was all about
getting revenge and so I think that
often you get to this destination and
you've kind of say okay now what now my
whole life is about getting to this
place but they didn't think about what
what's going to happen after so i think
reevaluating
if you feel that way and then try to
save yourself how could i reapply
because it's not like he didn't gain
something from the experience you gain
something from every experience and my
mom said this to me many many years ago
a good experience is what you get when
you don't get what you want and you know
just kind of think of it that way so I
don't believe it to be a mistake but I
think you need to reevaluate why you did
what you did where to go from there but
I don't think it's a something to panic
about
you